I make fresh butter at least once a week,
so let's make some roasted garlic and parsley butter today.
I start by roasting my bulb of garlic in the oven
and then pour some heavy cream into my Kitchen Aid.
I whisk it on a low to medium speed at first
while I chop up my parsley.
I give it a good chop
and make sure that it's small enough to incorporate into the butter.
Once my heavy cream reaches this stage,
I turn up the speed to a medium high speed
and just let it go until the buttermilk separates.
Once that happens,
I turn my mixer off and my butter is pretty much done.
Can use a strainer or your hands to just get all that buttermilk out.
Just make sure you get as much of it out as possible.
A lot of the times I ask lucky to come help me with this
since I'm not that strong.
Once all the buttermilk is pressed out,
I transfer my butter over to a plate,
sprinkle it with some parsley,
my roasted garlic,
some flaky sea salt,
and make sure that it's all incorporated
before I transfer it over to the fridge.
And some wax paper to store.